Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That number
is two one nine two. David, P.. This is so funny,
guys. You know how I sometimes tell you there
is a contingent of the left. I use the term
revolutionary leftist or Stalinist Leninist
leftists. Some of you prefer more pejorative
terms like tanky. I just I don't. I
don't. It's not a term that I use.
And I pointed out last week something that to most
of you, is now uncontroversial. There are leftists
who play coy with and defend and sometimes
straight up support. In the case of Maduro
in Venezuela, these revolutionary authoritarian
type figures that claim to be left but are really
failures of leftism anyway. A caller. Really
didn't like that. He says it doesn't exist,
is furious with me. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 6: Did I just hear you correctly to say
that some people on the left are in
favor of totalitarian regimes, are you?
Speaker 2: They won't call
Speaker 1: them totalitarian regimes,
but in the interests of claiming to be for
socialism or against American imperialism,
they will end up supporting those very things
Speaker 2: for
Speaker 6: real David. Yeah, no, that's
strong. You're a hundred and ten percent wrong.
That makes no sense at all what
some people on the left like me
are against fighting with Russia because
we don't like our imperialistic attitude.
Speaker 1: That's a different issue. And as I've
said it, I literally addressed this. You can't
just say I'm against American imperialism. So we
want to just say whatever Putin is doing is fine.
You can condemn something Putin does while saying,
I don't want the U.S. involved. For example,
you can condemn the insanity of the Chavez
Maduro regimes in Venezuela while saying,
I don't want the US picking a leader. I
don't want the U.S. pushing regime change,
u. I don't. These folks get so triggered by this
Speaker 6: U.S. imperialistic attitude.
That part that you said was correct,
but not people on the left are in favor
of totalitarian regimes. That makes no sense.
Speaker 1: Again, they would deny that they are
a threat. And by the way, I did the other things
I didn't say totalitarian. I said authoritarian.
So it's like, this is this is the perfect
example of someone denying reality and misstating
my position. But you know,
it's I'm used to it by now.
Speaker 6: They're not. They're not leftists.
If they are, are people on the right?
Only right will be in favor of that.
Speaker 1:
That's actually a really good
point. I believe that a lot of these
so-called leftists who say
Speaker 2: Putin's not bad and
Bashar al-Assad's not bad and
Speaker 1: Maduro is not bad, and Castro
was fine. And I that's my position is they're not
really on the left. They insist that they are,
but I would actually agree inadvertently with the
caller. I don't think those folks are actually
leftists anyway. That's a perfect example of what
I've been telling you guys about. We've got a
great bonus show for you today. We will talk about
the believed frontrunners for Joe Biden's Supreme
Court pick. We're going to talk about the hilarity
that has developed with Glenn Youngins tip line
to snitch on teachers. It's actually hilarious.
And we will talk about problems with the child
tax credit problems with the child tax credit in
terms of it actually being distributed to people.
We're going to talk about confusion around that
and much more on today's bonus show. You can sign
up at join Packman dot com to get instant access.
Unidentified: We will see you then or on tomorrow.